here's what would happen if you fell  into Jupiter at first due to the strong  gravity you'd be falling from the top of  the atmosphere at nearly 180  000 kilometers per hour at about 250  kilometers down you'd reach the ammonia  clouds and experience minus 150 degrees  Celsius temperatures as well as  incredibly powerful winds  about 12 hours into your fall the  temperature would now be rising and so  with the atmospheric pressure as you  reach the inner layers of Jupiter  there'd be parts that you'd be able to  swim through if you could handle it  since the temperature would be as hot as  the surface of the Sun and as if that's  not enough you'd also be experiencing  atmospheric pressure equal to 2 million  times the pressure on Earth  eventually you'd reach Jupiter's core  and you'd be stuck from all that  atmospheric pressure  so